when I say the word filmmaker
what comes to mind storytelling
um
people that
wants to make an impact
and people that wants to walk with the
elephants
people going to look at filmmaking as as
a industry that
for the artists for the people that want
to tell stories
they want to leave a legacy
and the people I think about filmmaking
as people that want to be in with a
community
that just wants to be a part of
something to be long
walk with the elephant
elephant yeah what is that
um you know walking with the celebrities
and the red carpets the the hooplas oh
the Giants the Giants yeah okay it's a
noble industry that's how I kind of look
at it yeah but where it's not a uh
yeah I mean it's like I'm a filmmaker
and they kind of lift this up oh hi I'm
a filmmaker right that's how I kind of
that's how I kind of think about it with
you know when I think about that but
when it comes to for me it's about uh
um impact
when I say the word entrepreneur
what comes to mind troubleshooting
solving problems
that's solving problem it's I think it's
about uh empowering people to
want to
make a change in industry and impact
people's lives same thing
and to be able to
[Music]
I would say to
move the generations forward
can you survive as a filmmaker if you're
not an entrepreneur
good question
yes if you are
if your content is good
and yes if you know
if your content is good yes and if you
are in a place
to in the place of good timing to be
able to have
good business people around you
if not then no
it's not the no is that the old adage
like you're only as good as the the
brightest one in your company or
something like that I don't even know
yeah or maybe you're as good as your
last film or
um look I think I think anything that's
creative is subjective and it's very
difficult and I think that in in the
creative world I think that it's
um I think that people don't value the
art form don't value art as much as
other Industries right and I think that
it's it's not tangible
in a way where people say oh my God you
know I you know it's uh it's something
that is so you know like it's like it's
an everyday job people don't look at
that way that's why it's that's why
films are scarce those films are rare
the good ones are
and people are not willing to pay for
the bad ones right
so that's why it's hard for filmmakers
in my opinion
do you enjoy a challenge do you rise to
the occasion if somebody says you can't
do something
I do
um
uh when my back's against the wall I I
would say that it's that's when I excel
um I did it for all my films and I did
it in my entrepreneurship Journey
um
I mean I'm not here to talk about my
background but you know I'm a refugee
immigrant from Vietnam
and I grew up with my back on the wall
all the time you know and it's always
been challenging so
um I don't think it's a matter of people
telling me that I can't do it I think
it's a matter of
just the nature of the job itself and
not wanting to disappoint people that
believes in you is the challenging part
you think normal things don't scare you
so you're you're ready to oh no one
thing scares me I'm scared of heights
and
I'm you know I'm um you know I'm
um
I think I think it's it's
um complacency scares me
your passion is storytelling before
building a business entrepreneurship
baseball oh baseball okay okay so
baseball and then and then storytelling
then music then music right music videos
uh no musician I was a record producer
and a songwriter oh and you went to
Juilliard right I went to Julia for
music and then I went and then
filmmaking because I couldn't I didn't
make it in music
but I thought that the medium was at the
filmmaking was a better medium than
music so I got into that you said you
didn't make it in music what is making
it I would say like uh defining it would
be like getting a hit record
um
making it as uh getting a hit record
Being able to have millions of people
across the world be able to listen to
the music and and and use that as a
platform to create change
that's how I defined it
who did you want to be like
Michael Jackson
at least the
what I wanted to see the music to affect
yeah
and at what point did you realize
it would either be a harder role than
you thought or you weren't it wasn't a
challenge you wanted to take on
no
um I just saw that the the business got
harder
you know
um you know with the ever you know with
the whole streaming
um the craziness of people just kind of
well in our industry was backstabbing
people
um you know nobody's honoring contracts
at least that's what I experienced and
then people want to take advantage you
over and over and over
um I I just kind of had enough with that
and I said I put it on pause and my
thought process was just like if I ever
had a chance to
um
come back in the game I'm gonna flip
this industry upside down
and I want to I want to be able to do it
right and really expose the problems and
then have a solution for that and that's
that was my mindset when when so I put
on I didn't give up on it I just put it
on pause and uh and then going into the
film industry
um I thought it was a little it was more
structured but like
more ethical people at least on this
filmmaking side of things oh it's more
ethical people there was more structure
there was more processes and uh and if
you understood that and then you
understood the business I thought there
was a better chance in making the film
industry than the music industry
how does a filmmaker's vision compare to
that of an entrepreneur
they go hand in hand
um
I think I think just back to just a
backtrack I think the I think you'll I
think your career and your life is
defined by your purpose and how you want
you know um and so everything I do from
music to films to entrepreneurship All
Leads back into wanting to impact
people's lives for the better right
however you do it I want to do it at
scale some but you know it actually does
feel good when you do impact people's
lives in general and so when it comes to
filmmaking it was a way to scale
the communications it's like I look at
filmmakers like the commercial way of
scaling of of an operation and
Entrepreneurship was like the vehicle to
be able to uh understand how this
problem solve and take business and then
and then still go through the same thing
of solving problems so that's so they
they all both they all go ahead and hand
to me and I think that it's um
um
I think for other people
um well I mean for other people they
think of film against filmmaking it's
like kind of they're pocket themselves
right for me I look at the whole entire
picture and I happen to be in filmmaking
I happen to be an entrepreneur because
my goal is to
um
update the innovate industries that I
think are problematic for the things
that we're passionate about
so if you took your favorite
entrepreneur
I'm not sure who that is Steve Jobs okay
good choice and your favorite filmmaker
Stevens to be at work okay great choice
and do you think they have similar dis
you know similar makeups yeah okay both
both are innovative
very Innovative Steven Spielberg changed
the game with his creative and
Innovations of films and how he takes it
to new levels and story time to a
different level storytelling is pretty
much structured very similarly a lot of
times right but how he
um you know I look at him as like the
the the person that knows how to tell
stories to kids
and he's able to tell those he's able to
create these fandoms and build this uh
Innovative I would call it Innovative
structure that allows people to be
inspired to make films
at you know uh not at his level but be
inspired to do films uh that want to do
films and I look at Steve Jobs as this
Innovative guy that's in technology that
that knows how to Target the kids right
and be able to create this
a luxury good for people to
um
change the world with
and I kind of look at it the same way
how would you compare risk taking
between filmmaking and Entrepreneurship
risk taking oh my gosh I think I think
filmmaking is a complete risk and I
think entrepreneurship is a complete
risk I think they both have to
there's no guarantees
for any any of that I think
entrepreneurship might be a little bit
safer than filmmaking you know I think
filmmaking is one of the
if not the the biggest risk of them all
right because
you spend your years trying to make a
film raising funds creating the scripts
onboarding people hoping people will
stay
employing if you had the money for it
and and then you put the product out and
then
it could get screwed right and people
don't like it no one wants to buy it
entrepreneurship is the same thing right
it's kind of like you know you spend
Maybe not maybe years or maybe months or
whatever it is developing the product
putting a team together
structured processes and raising money
to launch it and and you put it out
there and it doesn't happen so they're
both risky
um but I feel like
filmmaking is just a harder medium
because it's creative it's subjective
and Entrepreneurship is you could be
building a lemonade stands
you could be selling jewelry you could
sell whatever it is you want but it's
the same mechanism and it's and it's not
as direct it's not it's not like
filmmakers are
but some are but but majority it's not
filmmakers not going from B to C it's
usually go to B to B with a distributor
or sales agent wherever it is that
communicates to the sea levels right to
the community to the consumers in the
entrepreneurship world you're either
straight B to B which is contract
procurements and then you have your oh
you're going straight to like your
retail store going straight to a b2c
base and so I think it's um they're both
risky but yeah I think that filmmaking
is far more riskier than anything
there's the perception though that being
an entrepreneur is a safer route in that
it's business so it's seen as something
that's you know you're going to have a
widget that you're going to sell or a
service whereas filmmaking is not but
it's actually an illusion they're both
equally
equally risky because you can fail you
can have a great product and can sit on
the Shelf no one wants it now you've
bought all the stock a bigger fish can
come along
yeah
um
I think I think it depends on what kind
of Entrepreneurship you're doing right
let's say entrepreneurship Lane you
could be the entrepreneurship as uh but
entrepreneurship is not all created
equally I think entrepreneurship is if
you're a business owner you're a
business owner doesn't mean you're an
entrepreneur entrepreneur actually
solves problems the ones that want to
move the needle forward move want to
maybe possibly you want to change the
world maybe not at the scale of Steve
Jobs or Elon Musk but you still want to
solve industry problems and you get into
it because of that now some want to have
a title entrepreneur right but then you
got business owners that might run a
franchise
and they're not entrepreneurs they're
just franchise owners that just wants to
have some sort of passive income and
they have no intention of changing the
world or wanting to make any impact and
I think that that's that there's a clear
difference filmmaker you want to in a
filmmaking world I think that you got
storytellers that want to tell the
stories because they haven't they're
having fun telling stories and they want
to hopefully have people hear their
stories for whatever reason right and
there's multiple reasons for that and
then there's filmmakers that want to
just be a part of a community
and that's really it you know and I got
plenty of those people I think I would
say 99 of my employees all were
filmmakers but they don't want to be
filmmakers
because they don't work towards being
wanting a filmmaker you know what I'm
saying and I think that wanting to be a
filmmaker also means you want you have
to be an entrepreneur to run it